hier c'est cet après midi contes eu lieu
les obsèques de bernard laroche tué par
le père du petit grégory
les obsèques ont eu lieu dans le calme
et le recueillement sur place notre
envoyé spécial isabelle de chien avant
de refermer l'attendent
nous gardons rasées dans nos coeurs le
visage de bernard lui pour qui
maintenant tout est lumière et vérité
nous appellent à la vie
les camarades de travail de bernard
laroche était tous là pour soutenir sa
famille il assurait même un service
d'ordre discret pour éviter les
débordements dans ce petit cimetière au
mur d'enceinte hérissée de journalistes
la police était vigilante
le patron du srpj de nancy lui même
assisté à la cérémonie et des policiers
d'epinal dionnet la foule sans relâche
comme celui du petit grégory
l'enterrement de bernard laroche ne
pouvait pas être un enterrement comme
les autres la douleur des familles était
trop public depuis trop longtemps la
douleur et la rancoeur mais la peine de
la famille a pris le pas sur sa
lassitude face à la presse l'émotion
était digne malgré l'absurdité de cette
mort une absurdité confirmé la veille
encore par le juge d'instruction
quelques jours avant la mort de bernard
laroche
il s'apprêtait à lui signé une
ordonnance de non lieu mais la mort
brutale a mis fin au cours de la justice
il reste la douleur